why do you think
buddha see life is suffering
what's suffering okay well first of all
the
that is that gets mistranslated quite a
bit you're talking about the four noble
truths the first one is it often gets
translated as life is suffering which is
not
it it it's there is suffering the whole
life is suffering thing is just like the
spiritual version of life's a [ __ ] then
you die and people hear that they're
like yeah life is [ __ ] suffering but
it's there is suffering there is
suffering so
it's an affirmation
if you're like this this thing that a
lot of people feel that they associate
with lots of they have a lot of reasons
they think they're feeling it
is known as fundamental dissatisfaction
so so another word for suffering maybe
could be
fundamental dissatisfaction also
the term itself uh
maybe a better translation is wobbly
wheel
so like imagine like when your bike
doesn't have an or your car doesn't have
enough air in the tires your bike
doesn't have air in the tires it's kind
of a shitty bike ride like no matter
what just kind of like it's like
uncomfortable
it's like irritating so this is
what's being pointed to is that there's
this quality
within a human life
that is
um
unsatisfy like like a wobbly wheel
wobbly wheel why do you what why do you
think
what is at the core of that
dissatisfaction
because it could be uh it could be as
simple as kind of physical and mental
discomforts and
sadness and depression and all that kind
of stuff yeah or it could be more
speaking to the sort of existentialist
the philosophical
the absurdity of it all yep the fact
that stuff happens good stuff happens
for no reason bad stuff happens for no
reason yeah um yeah that it's
no matter how much you try
there's not
a universal fairness to the whole thing
there's not even a universal meaning to
the whole thing
so the existentialist perspective what
do you what what flavor of suffering do
you prefer oh it was an ice cream shop
that's so funny well i'm gonna i'm
definitely picking desire over the like
if in in the rgb that we're talking
about here is
desire
aversion
and ignorance so if you want to find
like the three
uh the the three ingredients that are
giving everyone their sophisticated
bits of suffering there you go that's
what what's uh in which way does desire
manifest itself in suffering it hurts
to lose to not have
like yeah it hurts to not like to
eternally not have but just like
my friend pointed this out he's like you
know like
you order something from amazon like
even in the smallest way you're excited
about whatever the thing is you order
this thing from amazon it's not coming
for four days so those four days are
going to be somewhat marked by you being
what people say i'm excited about it
but really if you look at that feeling
it's uncomfortable like the feeling of
wanting the thing is uncomfortable so
that is a form of suffering that's
suffering
interesting i mean i wonder
because we naturally reframe that in our
mind
wanting
we reframe that as a good thing as
um and maybe suffering is
fundamentally good
in the way we think of what life is
like it's life affirming
but it's not usually how the word
suffering is used well it's true
it's true like the first noble truth of
buddhism is true it's called the truth
of suffering there is suffering i mean
this is like an i don't know an element
that you can't break it down any further
than that like there is suffering this
is truth so
if you think
you know and again assigning like good
or bad to truth i think maybe
there's more of a sort of neutrality
there it's just what it is it's truth i
mean is it any is it basically is
suffering any disturbance
uh from stillness
is suffering then
like basically any any anything that
happens in life that
uh
that's like that perturbs the system
ripples in the end ripples ripples yeah
so a still lake is is empty of suffering
but any kind of ripple
is is suffering in that sense a still
lake is empty of suffering
you sound like a zen master seems like
something is in masturbation if i can
just grow a beard like yours ah no the
beard doesn't help
your chin you think i'd have a [ __ ]
beard i look like a stork you should see
me if i had your chin there would be no
beard here no you have a symmetrical
nice chin this is the closest i can come
to plastic surgery pubic plastic surgery
friend
that's how you know you're a
professional comedian uh
yes it's suffering they're suffering
and
the lake
analogy is pretty good because
the um
what's happening here is that that
we have become
identified with something that we call a
self so
this the self is just accepted i have a
self i have an identity i'm a person i
have a self
but when you
start doing scans to try to find
yourself which is the entire thing i'm
going to find
myself you get in a van go to california
take some acid
[ __ ] a prostitute on the bus or whatever
kerouac did i'm gonna find myself she
didn't
he she wasn't a prostitute just to
correct the record oh previously
prostitute i guess once a prostitute was
a prostitute you know what she's a
former i don't think that no and look
i'm not as i
i
not assigned it look all i'm saying is
uh i don't care who cares who has a bit
of prostitute god you are used to be one
of them we're all guessing we're all
kind of a kind of prostitute yeah yes
yes but the the i make love and we make
money
therefore we're all a kind of prostitute
we make god how great i would really
love to be able to make money by [ __ ]
i mean it's maybe not directly but in
some sense directly
do you accept venmo
never too late to start that's so sort
of one of the ways in is this sort of
contemplation of the identity because
it's like
uh
you know what it's it's not just the
desire it's what is having the desire
where does the desire live in like what
doesn't want to be where it's at what is
the thing that is like uh
desperately wanting to get out of the
situation it's in and then um as far as
ignorance uh it's still something that's
theoretically happening to an identity
so
so wrapped up in it is really just this
sort of like and that's where we run
into what
into attachment so if
if the first noble truth of buddhism is
there is suffering
the second noble truth of buddhism is um
the cause
of
this suffering is attachment and so
people hear that and they take it that's
a there's a lot of levels to that
concept definitely the cause of
suffering is attachment i mean god i
just got addicted to vapes is there a
more embarrassing addiction than vapes
i'm smoking like a little purple thing
it tastes like sugar it's attachment it
is there is suffering i want it i have
to charge it now i'm embarrassed by it
it makes me feel out of control there's
a lot of suffering but
also
there's deeper levels of attachment that
go all the way to this
attachment to the sense of one's self
and the i think the existentialists do
get into this idea in a different way
which is like
because i think i'm a me
now i have to push
what that thing is out into the world
through my actions and that's a kind of
attachment too
exactly there you go right and that
leads to the third noble truth which is
get rid of attachment
and you won't suffer anymore
uh that's it seems logical but you know
it is a very
it is a mathematical analysis of
uh this particular problem of suffering
it's addressing and then the fourth
noble truth is the eightfold path of
buddhism which is like a
a process by which one could
unencumber
oneself from this identification with
something that isn't real
you